n on retrouve Emmanuel Chaze notre envol
spécial à Kiev comment les mesures
prises par leur président ukrainien
volodimear Zelinski contre la corruption
sont vécues par les Ukrainiens
et bien écoutez je lui dis qu'il ne faut
pas oublier que ce Président vous le dit
mirzelinski a été élu notamment avec ses
promesses de de cibler justement cette
corruption et d'endiguer cette cette
corruption de la supprimer au plus haut
au plus haut de l'État et c'est ce que
c'est la tâche à laquelle semble s'être
atelier ce gouvernement ces derniers
jours on a même vu des arrestations et
des démissions en série après des
révélations des soupçons de corruption
jusqu'au sein du ministère de la Défense
je pense par exemple à cette affaire qui
vise le vice-ministre de la Défense qui
aurait signé des contrats
d'approvisionnement de l'armée douteux
et bien cette affaire révélée par les
médias ukrainiennes a été prise très au
sérieux immédiatement on a vu une série
de démission au sein de ce ministère
c'est un signal fort envoyé par
volodymir Zelenski c'est un signal qui
est bien reçu ici par la population une
population qui sait que son adhésion
hypothétique à l'Union européenne et
bien elle est tributaire de ce ménage
qui est fait au sein de ses institutions
donc c'est un travail en cours Charles
Michel Lady il y a du chemin à faire
mais c'est un chemin qui est pris et
bien pris par les ukrainiens et par son
gouvernement par leur gouvernement par
merci beaucoup Emmanuel Chaze en direct
de Kiev merci à vous